son raros no siempre huelen bien pero me
encanta dar clases en secundaria
son sorprendentes y es una edad esencial
en términos de instrucción y aprendizaje
y si encuentras la forma de causarles
una impresión a esa edad realmente
puedes dirigirlos por buen camino para
tener éxito y oportunidades
disfruto mucho enseñar matemáticas
porque siento que muchas veces los
alumnos tienen experiencias terribles
con ellas así que me apasiona mucho el
llenar esos huecos con los chicos y
crear una experiencia significativa con
las matemáticas que les permita aceptar
e incluso amar las matemáticas
cuando empecé al inicio de este año los
alumnos estaban increíblemente atrasados
en matemáticas estaban en sexto con un
nivel más bien entre el segundo y creo
que el más alto tenía un nivel de
principios de cuarto año así que en
promedio tenían dos o dos años y medio
de atraso
estuve en un congreso de escuelas
subvencionadas en san diego el año
pasado y sanz cnd dio una conferencia
sobre khan academy creó una gran
impresión y yo también estaba muy
emocionado estaba platicando con las
personas a mi lado y decían quiero hacer
esto en mi salón no sé cómo lo voy a
hacer me voy a revelar si es necesario
para conseguir las computadoras y hacer
esto así que después de la conferencia
de sal regresé y comencé a usarlo
puse a los alumnos que más batalla van a
usar khan academy les encantó
creo que tomando en cuenta la edad de
nuestros alumnos la tecnología es muy
importante en sus vidas está en todas
partes
estaban muy emocionados con khan academy
decían si lo logré ya entiendo las
divisiones y antes no las entendía
puedo usar la información para dividir a
los alumnos en grupos y puedo
concentrarme en los que están batallando
mucho en ciertas áreas
también puedo ver al grupo como un todo
por ejemplo si el grupo termina un
módulo como este de múltiplos comunes
y si ya lo dominan antes de que yo lo
enseñe en clase
entonces ya sé que no tengo que
dedicarle tanto tiempo a esto así que
como maestro me ha liberado mucho tiempo
que puedo usar de manera más eficiente y
eso me ha ayudado mucho como maestro en
la clase para impulsar mucho a los
chicos les ayuda a progresar hacia el
siguiente grado pero también les ayuda
como matemáticos en general
cuando comencé al principio de este año
algunos les gustaban las matemáticas
pero a la mayoría no
icann ha sido una herramienta muy
valiosa en términos de simplemente
convencerlos tengo un alumno que resalta
especialmente él dice antes odiaba las
matemáticas ahora me encantan
ya no sólo tienen acceso al plan de
sexto año sino que lo pasan con éxito
algunos de ellos han crecido dos años en
términos de matemáticas
khan academy les permite regresar si no
entendieron o si lo entendieron para
hacerlo de una manera diferente
es simplemente muy asombroso verlos ahí
en khan academy por su cuenta buscando
vídeos relacionándolo todo con lo que
vemos en clase y muy motivados por
hacerse cargo de su propio aprendizaje